let's get started um good afternoon
everyone um my name is venkat gurswami
i'm a senior scientist here at the
simons institute for the theory of
computing
and thanks to everyone both in the room
and
remote for joining us for today's
richard m karp distinguished lecture
first a brief background about this
lecture series we established the series
at the simons institute to celebrate the
role of simon's institute founding
director dick carp
in establishing the field of theoretical
computer science formulating its central
problems and contributing really
stunning results
in the areas of algorithms and
computational complexity
and the series
happens you know has about four lectures
each semester and features visionary
leaders in the field of theoretical
computer science and the lectures are
geared towards a broad scientific
audience
and
we are really grateful to the many
contributors to the richard m karp fund
who have made this series possible
and
coming to today's talk i'm really
delighted to welcome today's speaker uh
constantinos uh costas das kalakis
uh kostis is a professor of electrical
engineering and computer science at mit
uh he got his undergraduate degree at
the national technical and university of
athens and kostas is no stranger to uc
berkeley he got his phd here
and and also to simon's institute where
he is actually an organizer or
co-organizer of both the programs
this semester i'm not sure if that has
ever happened before so he's a familiar
figure here
and in terms of his work he works he has
done major works at the
interface of
theory of computing and game theory and
economics
and he has proved
it was all long-standing open problems
on the complexity of nash equilibria and
multi-item
auctions
and his work has also touched upon many
topics at the interface of cs theory and
probability theory machine learning and
statistics and one of his recent focus
is high dimensional statistics um
and learning from uncertain and
strategic data so he has won um
his works over the years have been
recognized with many prestigious honors
and to just mention a few highlights uh
his thesis won the acm doctoral
dissertation award and his most recent
awards include
the royal flambellina prize from the
international mathematical union and
also the acm grace maria hopper award so
today his talk is entitled equilibrium
computation and machine learning
and please join me in welcoming costas
thanks very much venkat for the uh very
kind and warm introduction
it is my great pleasure to give the uh
richard carp uh lecture
uh
yeah i mean uh it's uh
richard carp is uh you know one of one
of the giants uh
in our field uh
very inspiring uh very kind uh
uh a
person with you know uh
enthusiasm towards research and uh he
was a transpiration when i was a student
uh here
uh so
these are slides by richard carp
on the visit days
when i came to berkeley in 2004
and
we sort of like to summarize uh
you know one of the aspects of how
dick views computation as transformative
not just for computing the field of
computing but also
as a lens to
study
sciences broadly
and of course
you know he was uh
supported in this quest by other uh
people of berkeley then and now uh that
you see here
and another feel another thing that
makes carp
special is uh you know uh
uh also i mean his amazing contributions
to the field
and um
uh his uh you know you know what he
appreciates in in in those contributions
so this is a course announcement from
when i was a student i tried hard to
find it in my email but i found it today
so that the the class was called great
algorithms
and uh here's uh an intro to to to the
class
that sort of like shows uh you know what
carp appreciates in in
algorithmic contributions so from time
to time a new algorithm comes along that
causes a sensation in theoretical
computer science or in an area of
application because of its resolution of
a long-standing open question
a surprising efficiency the novelty of
the setting or the approach
the elegance of its structure the
subtlety of its analysis or its range of
applications
you present a variety of these
algorithms
mostly drawn from
the following list you can
quickly skim through the list
but
i think that that little snippet
summarizes uh you know the fact that uh
you know
something about uh the essence of what
dick uh
uh
appreciated and uh you know what
he
inspired his students and collaborators
to do
i also want to thank
dick for adopting me when i was
graduating from berkeley
so christos was traveling during the uh
uh a commencement and he barely missed
me so he here's christos with his fancy
cyprus uh you know gown
from from southwest university coming
from the airport he barely missed me so
uh karp stepped in to adopt me and hood
me that day okay so thank you very much
uh dick for being an inspiration and
uh for all your contributions to to the
to the to the field
all right so let me you know now dive
into the technical part of the
presentation uh i want to talk about
some beautiful points of contact between
uh a game theory optimization and
machine learning and i'm gonna talk
about uh
two results
uh
uh this paper with uh strategically
likes and manuals and patakis and this
very recent work that's you know started
last semester at mit and we just
completed with no goal of which and
cachings and while being assignments
so you might have seen
first part
but you know this is the new component
that i'm adding to it
so machine learning has made a lot of uh
progress uh in here to four uh
challenges uh
machine learning you know learning
challenges
and many of this progress from an
optimization standpoint
looks like
you know becomes a minimization problem
so
a lot of this progress is enabled by
formulating learning challenges and
minimization problems that involve high
dimensional variables
and functions loss functions that are
non-convex
and they're essentially only accessible
via first order information value
queries and gradient value quiz
and which
you know many times are at least
lipsticks differentiable and smooth at
least almost everywhere
now this the corresponding problems are
difficult problems uh there won't be
hard problems
uh and because of the high
dimensionality
of these problems really
one that doesn't have many options for
how to uh
solve them
a very prominent you know method used to
solve these problems is great in descent
which uh of course does not is not
guaranteed to find globally optimal
solutions but at least it finds uh
locally optimal solutions which in
practice work well for the a lot of
those applications
in the past few years we've also seen an
emergence of multi-agent learning
[Music]
applications
from playing difficult games
to
multi-agents interactions involving
robots or other agents
to applications that are not explicitly
game theoretic but where a game
theoretic formulation
enables us to attain learning outcomes
that are useful such as training deep
generated models and protecting
classifiers from other serial attacks
now
those formulations are not optimization
problems but but they
correspond to
games
um involving multiple legends
and those games
in those games the agents make high
dimensional decisions
using you know vectors near high
dimensional vectors
and some constraints set they often
impose those agents often and post
constraints on each other like if a
robot goes somewhere maybe another robot
cannot go to the same place so i'll be
denoting the constraints set by s
constraining the joint actions of all
agents and like what was happening in
the
minimization space i was talking about
before
uh the utilities functions of those
agents are uh typically
non-concave
in the uh in an agent's own actions
equivalently the loss function that an
agent wants to minimize
is not convex in their own actions
and that is a big departure from the
settings that classically are started in
game theory
where uh
uh
you know
you know typical settings in both game
theory and economics involve agents who
try to maximize
a utility function that is concave or
quasi-concave in their own actions
so here very naturally you get
games where agents are maximizing
non-concave
utility functions and that's a big
departure as i'm going to describe
shortly from the classical setting
also typically ages don't really know a
close form of their utilities functions
they can interact with their utility
function
they can get function value queries or
gradient function value queries but
you know the higher order information
becomes
more and more expensive
and as before i mean many settings
those utility functions are at least
lipsticks differentiable and smooth in
an agent's actions
so i'm going to be calling these games
smooth because of this property
non-concave games because of this
non-concavity
of the utilities
and what makes these problems
challenging is that uh
a lot of game theory goes out of the
picture the moment you introduce
non-concavity for example equilibria do
not exist in these non-concave games
and this is a trivial example where this
happens two players zero-sum game one
player wants to
come as close as possible to the other
player the other agent wants to go as
far as possible from the other player
there's no equilibrium in this game
you could consider you to try to
convexify the setting by
playing distribution on this constraint
and uh you may or may not have
equilibrium resistance then even if you
do that you may not actually have a
little existence
and again where this happens for example
is the guess the larger number game it's
a zero-sum game with different players
whoever
reports the highest number
wins a point from the other player
uh
you know he gets
you know
basically players chase each other to
infinity in this game so this has been
started in the literature uh
but uh yeah it's not extra big strides
it's not a magic wand okay
[Music]
but uh also from a practical point of
view you don't want to have
distributions or
parameters of the diameter okay so um
yeah so but certainly this is the
direction that is worth studying and
that has been started but anyway so
uh these games do not have equilibria
and you know the main goal of this
line of work
is
what are then meaningful solution
concepts in this setting
and are they practically attainable
so by meaningful i mean that at the very
least there should be that should exist
they should exist in every non-concave
game
and they should be verifiable with the
information that agents have about their
own utilities
by practically attainable i would like
them to be also efficiently computable
via some
lightweight methods like great and
descent or
something like that
yeah again
matters but something that just picked
up from the last thing you said in
response to the last question do you
want to use the link sure
so it uh it
seems here like you're talking about
whether you have uh concavity in the
decisions but uh in just a moment ago
you said something about concavity in
the parameters of the deep neural
network which might be um something that
induces the decisions uh you know much
higher dimensional than the decision
space itself is that distinction gonna
matter to us i mean should we
i mean otherwise it seems pretty natural
to think about uh you know discrete
parameters that induce a distribution
over decisions so let me give a concrete
example and then let me return to your
uh uh question okay um yeah i mean uh
a motivating example for this line of
work is training deep generated models
the goal the goal of deep generating
models is to
uh
okay so
is to find parameters of a deep neural
network that has the following uh
interesting property
uh it takes us a bit boring randomness
so samples from an isotropic gaussian
and outputs interesting randomness
except for example
faces that you know could be coming from
uh
the probability distribution of
celebrity
faces sitting in some platonic space
right so
um
uh so uh how do people what is one way
to get
parameters for
for a neural net achieving this very
nice property
a proposal by good fellow atel is to set
up a two player zero sum game
between two agents
a generator a generator an agent
controlling the the variables of this
neural network
and another agent controlling the
parameters of a different neural network
who is uh trying to distinguish between
real samples and fake samples okay so
this guy takes us input boring samples
and is supposed to produce good samples
this guy is getting samples that are
either coming from the generator or from
the true distribution of celebrities
and it's supposed to uh
say one if they see a
true sample and zero if they see a
example
they want to distinguish between the two
distributions
are there many
ways people assign utilities to the
players of this uh architecture but
here's one called wasserstein gown by
czechoslov
over here
you ask the discriminator to maximize
this utility function written here
this utility function is the expected
difference in the output of the
discriminator
when you plug
into the discriminator a real sample
versus a fake sample a sample that has
gone through a neural network and
into the discriminator so you ask the
discriminator to maximize this utility
function you ask the discriminator to
minimize this utility function and here
you see how
the decisions made by display the
players of this game you know
you know our parameters of neural
network
networks that uh you know come into the
utility function causing this known
uh
uh concavity uh in the utilities now to
come to your question kevin i guess
you could say oh you know like rather
than
choosing parameters of a neural network
let me
choose a distribution over faces okay
that is too high dimensional and
practical there's no
good description of uh
you know how the good parametric
description of how this may look like
and
uh here you're postulating that maybe
parameterizing this distribution as a
neural net
uh could lead to good samples
uh
all right so coming back to the uh
original thread like so you see here how
you know with this interaction of neural
networks you see how non-concavity
may arise
and
to my previous point
equilibria do not exist in this case
there is no x and y that necessarily are
an equilibrium
of a general problem like this
and um
in the absence of such a solution
concept the question is what does game
theory predict in this case okay so
maybe game theory says okay you should
compacify the settings somehow impose
some compactness do this or that or the
other and maybe equilibrium start
arising
but uh you know that that you know that
that is a possible uh avenue
but uh uh is not really what uh
would be a practical solution when you
say yeah just curious in this excuse me
this gan example um so typically it's
not concave are there are there are
rigorous results saying that um
specifically for wasserstein gan that
equilibria don't exist
it's context and killed so
you still have a
specific space no
correct i agree with that
no i agree with that so you could talk
about the distribution of our
distributions but what i was saying
earlier this is not practical so you
have to
like what you do here is you
parameterize the submission in a way
that actually leads to good results
yeah you could have you know you can
have one player certain space of all
possible functions to classify
another respect to all distributions
over
uh you know a million dimensions
uh you know
yes maybe the problem will be complex
there but now you're hit with a lot of
statistical issues right like
if you think that the world is sampling
a general distribution in a million
dimensions like thousand by thousand
pixels
uh then uh
you know statistics tells you that
you know explanation many samples in a
million to be able to uh
you know learn a distribution so
that's not a good way to go about this
problem because of statistical issues
correct but i guess let me put it this
way let's uh take that over
you know
over you know the discussion section
because this is not even the main point
of the talk it's just an illustrative
example of
how you get non-convex thing in general
right so
um
now okay coming back to this equilibrium
exists uh what do people do about it
well people try
and what they try to do is to have
agents run their own methods their own
grading descent
method to optimize their own parameters
so they do this
simultaneous creating ascent in their
own utilities and practically this
doesn't is very
problematic so
oftentimes uh
having the two agents of a of such a
game
uh
around their own variant of greater
descent
leads to
either cycling behavior or you know
leading to bad solutions not the
what you would like uh
to happen okay so these are two examples
of showing
a target distribution so in here you
want to sample not from faces but from
hundreds and digits
and here you see what the generator is
sampling
if you stop the training
at different steps
over here the target distribution is a
mixture of gaussians whose means are in
a cycle and again here you see
what the generator generates if you stop
the training at different steps
people add add a lot of bells and
whistles trying to stabilize uh
grain descent
in this
types of settings but it is a challenge
to train and um
you know that
that was given as a little example to to
motivate you know how non-concavity
arises
and uh
you know uh the lack of equilibria and
uh
you know the types of questions that
arise motivating you know the question
that is here on the slide
okay um
so
let me start with a
simple
idea
for what would be a local notion okay so
like i was saying earlier that in a
single agent setting we are targeting
local minima as opposed to global
minimum
what if we try to do something similar
here okay so this would be the analog of
local minima or local maxima
so
i would say i'll say that a a strategy
profile x-star
comprising a
an action for each agent
is a first-order local nash equilibrium
if the following condition holds for
every agent
let's try to parse it
so here what's happening is that the
agent is trying to do a gradient ascent
step
trying to max it to improve their
utility
keeping the actions of the other agents
fixed and trying to do a greater step
with respect to their own variables from
this point x i star right so they try to
make an improvement
then they project
uh you know remember there were
constraints that tie everybody's
decision so they make they try to make
an improvement they project back down to
the constraints imposed on them
by the actions that the other agents
choose
and if that attempt
doesn't go anywhere i'm gonna i'm gonna
say that the the point is that nashville
is a local national it you know the
agent attempts to improve
uh but uh they don't go anywhere okay
i'm gonna be calling that a nash a local
nash equilibrium
so pictorially a local nash equilibrium
is a point x1 through x x1 star through
x and star such that every agent finds
themselves in one of these two uh
situations
so this orange shape is the constraints
imposed on agent eye by the other
players
this is the the the the set of actions
by everyone else
so this is the constraint imposed on
agent i by the actions of the other
players
so
a player is
at a local optimum
if one of these cases happens right so
either what they're playing now is on
the boundary of this constraint set and
if they try to make a step to improve
they're going to land at the point that
is outside and projecting down into the
set it gives them the same point
or they're inside but the graded is zero
so
first order information doesn't tell you
you know anything about what to do
locally
so
local nash equilibrium is a point where
the action played by agent i is the best
response to the action played by the
other agents at least as far as the
first order information the first order
approximation to an agent's utility
function is concerned
this is what
is the natural generalization of local
minima
in this case
all right so
uh
all right so this is a relaxation of
nash right so nash will tell you that no
matter where you go you can't improve
here you're only asking about a greedy
step using a first-order approximation
to your utility
so it's a relaxation so at the very
least
that this would be stable
and uh the questions doesn't exist uh
and it's actually pretty easy because of
this fixed point form that it has it's
very easy to show
that if the constraint set that
constrains all the actions of everybody
together is convex and compact then this
thing is guaranteed to exist
so at the very least it is universal
and it is verifiable with the little
info that agents have about their
utilities
so what this point is trying to capture
is
uh
agents finding themselves at the place
where
jiggling their actions locally doesn't
give them utility so
they they may say okay like at least
as far as local perturbations are
concerned i'm happy with what i'm doing
given what the other agents are doing
okay
so this could be robots trying to
control their joints or you know agents
in the gown or whatever so
but
okay so at least you know this thing is
guaranteed to exist it's a it's a bare
minimum right so if you don't like this
notion
uh
i i'm not necessarily proposing just a
no it's the right notion right but
i'm showing it as the natural uh
generalization of what a local minimum
is or what the local maximum is
uh in the single agent case and you know
i'd claim that this is the you know bare
minimum that
a reasonable solution of this
non-concave game should satisfy it
should at least satisfy that an agent
cannot locally jiggle their actions
to improve their utility right with
information that they have about their
utility
question
so you gave us examples
you gave us some examples before where
the global nash equilibrium wouldn't
exist but those all those examples if i
understood them correctly were
non-compact i'm wondering if there are
examples that are convex and compact
where a first order local nash
equilibrium exists but a global one
doesn't yeah so the example that i gave
you earlier this x minus x two squared
also if you if the constraint is compact
like minus one one for all legends it
also doesn't have it it's not a matter
but it will have a local nash
equilibrium it will have a logo yeah
okay
um and i think it's the zero zero point
uh all right so okay so at least
this is the bare bones of what the
solution constantly satisfy question is
is it practically attainable you know
um
so it looks that it isn't right i mean
the fixed points of gradient descent
ascend which is what people do in gans
has this you know
as i was saying earlier the fixed points
of this procedure is
don't amount to my solution concept
so
i was saying earlier that people trying
to do gradient descent ascent gradient
ascent in in these types of settings
struggle
with uh stabilizing the dynamics so what
do they struggle
um could it be that it's because of some
underlying interactability
and
the main
one of the main results of this talk is
that indeed this is the case and a very
strong sense so
even if you have two players and the
interaction is zero sum like in a gun
uh but your utilities are not concave
then
any first order method so any method
that accesses utilities through first
and second
through zero and first order information
uh requires exponentially many queries
uh
uh in the dimension of the problem and
the approximate or the approximation
uh to compute uh and approximate uh
local nash equilibrium
so this is a query complexity lower
bound it says that uh if you you know
any method uh
you know uh
that queries the utilities uh uh making
first order queries to them
will have to spend exponential time
to give you even this very weak solution
concept
okay
so that's a query complexity lower bound
you may ask okay like okay uh all right
how about second order or third order
maybe i can expand spend some more time
and get the hessian and the
third order uh derivative and so on and
so forth what happens then
so uh
you know not much uh is improved i mean
so uh there is a computational lower
bound that says that
in the same class of two players in some
games
any method first order second order or
whatever
needs super polynomial time
uh
in the dimension and or the
approximation to find a
approximation approximate local nash
equilibrium unless some complexity
theoretical collapse takes place which
is the
epd collapses to p
so we have a query complex for first
order methods exponential queries
or a super polynomial for any method
first order secondary or or whatever
now i realized that piper is not a
familiar class it's not as famous as you
know the class that the carp was working
on
in the 70s
but it's in between p and np okay it
lies somewhere in between
and it contains uh some difficult
problems like finding approximate var
fixed points of ellipses functions
computing nash equilibria mixed nash
equilibria in normal form games so games
with a finite number of actions and
players choosing distributions over uh
those actions
and you know several other problems in
combinatorics and
topology
so
our result said differently is that
computing local nash equilibria even in
two players or some smooth non-concave
games
is exactly as hard as these two problems
and at least as hard as any other
problem in this class
um
i'm not going to give a proof but i want
to give some intuition about why even
two players are too
all
many
why is it that if you have a single
agent trying to minimize a non-convex
loss function
you can do that efficiently
while uh if you have even a two players
or some interaction where people have
non-concave
utilities or not equivalently non-convex
losses in their own actions that is a
difficult problem
so to convey some intuition about the
difference the big difference between
these two problems
i want to consider objective improving
paths
in this space in this type of problems
and also in this type of form
so in a non-convex
optimization problem
if you consider objective improving
steps by the optimizing player
you ought to see the objective function
decreasing okay so here i'm showing
how the objective values may look like
in a non-convex minimization problem
uh along an objective improving path
that the optimizing agent can follow
may follow
right so what you see is that the you
know objective improvement
paths the function values have to go
down
and in particular if
the
optimizing agent
doesn't just make optimizing move but
but moves that guarantee them at least
some epsilon improvement
and if your objective function is lower
bounded
then you're chipping away progress
towards the
you know the the absolute lower bound so
you are guaranteed to converge uh as as
you as you walk on a
uh
on such a path and you know the number
says is going to be polynomial in the
one over epsilon because you're chipping
away epsilon
and there's if the function is bounded
there's an absolute floor right
so that's what's happening and this is
roughly why gradient descent converges
this is essentially what it is
um
in a two players there or some games
things are more funky okay
so here i'm showing you
the objective value
how the objective value may look like in
a two player zero sum game where
horizontal moves are by minimizing
player it's a zero sum game so one try
to minimize and one tries to maximize an
objective function the same objective
function horizontal moves are those are
corresponding to the minimizing player
vertical moves to the maximizing player
and i'm showing here possible values for
the objective along
a better response path by the players
so of course horizontal moves have to
decrease the objectives vertical moves
have to increase the objective
because they correspond to these two
players
and uh here are two interesting
observations
so first of all better response dynamics
might be cyclic this is a better
response dynamic
uh you cannot have cyclic
objective improvement path over here
over here you could have cycles
the other thing i want to observe is
that
you could see repetition of values even
if it's not if even if a better is
better response path uh is non-cyclic
you could see repetitions of values of
the objective like here like three two
one
one two three three two one and so forth
um so in particular querying the
objective value somewhere
along
even a non-cyclic better response path
doesn't offer much information about how
far from the end of this path
you are so the end of the path it would
be
a local nash equilibrium but
the fact that these values can repeat
themselves along this path
is problematic it doesn't give you much
info about the location of these local
nationals
this is intuition
uh to turn this intuition into
an actual query lower bound
what you'd like to do is to cook up an
objective function such that
a better response dynamics
you know are a serpentine-like space
filling path in some ambient space
so with repetition of values so that
acquiring uh the objective anywhere on
the path doesn't give you much info
about the location of local
nashes
so we're not able to do this to execute
on this intuition
uh uh and instead so so rather than
proving the query complexular bound
first we first establish the
computational lower bound the ppd
completeness of
against any algorithm
and the fact that the fact that our
reduction
was black box allowed us to
inherit some query complex lower bounds
from the computation of briar fixed
points to
this problem
so we first showed the computational
result and then showed the query
complexity lower bound
this is roughly why though
two players are too many
um
i want to draw philosophical corollary
from uh uh this result right so again
i i i really try to replicate the notion
of the solution concept from
minimization problems so i really tried
to here to replicate this notion of
local minima or local maximum
which has been driving progress in
single agent
deep learning
right where you you know what you do
like the paradigm there is
you pick a model that is maybe very
complex you collect a lot of data and
access to to get access to a super
computer and then you train the heck out
of your loss function using gradient
descent or some variant of that method
so here i tried to replicate this in the
multi-agent setting
and i failed very badly right so i i uh
extended this notion of local minimum to
the multi-agent world so
giving rise to these local nashes
but uh
which is again a very weak solution
concept not
necessarily what you would like from
your gun or what you would like from
your robots interacting with each other
and nevertheless i already hit lower
bounds
so my corollary from this is that
in the multi-agent world and this is a
call to arms really in the multi-agent
world you need to do a lot more work in
understanding your underlying
application with domain experts
uh in order to model it appropriately
understand
how your learning model should look like
not just any arbitrary neural nets
understanding what are meaningful
solution concepts that maybe bypass
these lower bounds tractability results
and coming up with an algorithm that
attains these solution concepts
and i think
only then we might get uh
more successes like uh alphago and and
and libratus
uh which uh are not just uh neural nets
playing games but uh they actually in
how these uh uh are trained in fact
libertus has no neural nets in it uh but
uh the you know the way these algorithms
are trained is actually using the
uh structure the game theoretic
structure of the corresponding games all
right so that's my little
philosophical corollary
and before i conclude let me spend a
little time a few slides on
some progress towards realizing this
okay
and that progress pertains to the
problem of multi-agent reinforcement
learning which is the multi-agent
generalization of reinforcement learning
so uh
right so what okay so uh and in
particular
uh just you know in case you are not
familiar with the background let me uh
tell you a little bit the mathematical
foundation of reinforcement learning and
multi-agent reinforcement learning which
are correspondingly mark of decision
processes and stochastic games
so the market decision process you have
an agent and a system
the the system has state the agent
submit actions to the system and get
back a
reward
that depends on the current state and
the action that they chose
and a state transition that follows the
dynamics of the system
uh
commonly in
market decision processes
you care about stationary markov
policies which specify
which recommend an action a distribution
over actions for every state
these are called mark markov and
stationary because
uh stationary because they don't depend
on the time of the interaction what
little t is the gestationary and they're
markup because they don't depend on the
history they just depend on the current
state
these types of recommendations are
called stationary markov policies
and what agents typically try to do in
this kind of settings is to maximize
their long-term discounted rewards
so an agent
wants to find a policy
such that over an infinitely long path
that starts at some state as not
and
[Music]
at every step has the agent choose an
action from their policy and gets a
state transition from the system
dynamics
uh you know so you sample a law an
infinite path like that and you
accumulate uh the rewards that aids and
gets along this path
discounted by some gamma at every step
so this is what we do in mdps
uh stochastic games are the
n dimensional and agent analog of that
so you know you have many agents
submitting actions to the system
the state transition depends on the
current state and the actions chosen by
everybody
and the rewards to an agent depend on
the state and the actions chosen by
everybody
the analog of a stationary markov policy
here specifies a recommendation of
actions for everybody at every state
and again the agent's objective is for
an infinitely long path sampled
following the
recommendations of the policy and the
state dynamics
uh the reward that an agent accumulates
so it's a the exact generalization of
the single agency to the multi-agent
world
now
what is a good solution for this so over
here the good solution is find a policy
pie
that maximizes this
value for the agent
what is a good solution over here well
this is a game so there are many kinds
of solutions
[Music]
here's one
started
proposed by sharply and started a lot in
game theory
it's stationary markov nash equilibrium
a stationary mark of nash equilibrium
is a policy pie with the extra property
that it's a product measure so every
agent at every state independently
samples
uh their action okay so this is the
product measure here so you want to find
a policy pie that's a product measure so
that
every player i
for every player lie and for every
alternative policy that they may
want to use
rather than their policy in this product
measure
their value would decrease or would not
increase if they were to switch
to that policy pie tilde
now
interestingly enough these things exist
as long as you have non-trivial
discounted discount factor
and this is quite surprising and this is
kind of like motivates this part of the
talk this is quite surprising because
the values are not concave in the policy
pie
policy pie
you know affects the trajectory that you
fall in and you know because you may
come back to states
uh your utility is not uh
uh conv concave in in the policy pie
or your own poll is in this measure
so in this product policy so it is
surprising that these things exist but
they do exist
um
and you know what i want to figure out
is can they be computed
right but
here's a weaker notion of equilibrium
called stationary markov course
correlated equilibrium this is a the
same thing except you don't restrict the
policy to be a product measure you allow
you you want to find a
a policy that might correlate the action
chosen by people at every step
that's a stationary mark of course
correlated
so what do we know about computing
optimal policies here and optimal and
equilibria over here we're on the single
agent case we know a lot there is a lot
of
methods there are a lot of methods for
finding optimal policies and a lot of
recent work also
that think about the problem of learning
policies in in in settings where you
don't know the environment
but
you have to
learn a policy learn as much about the
environment as you need to learn a good
policy
um on that side though
um
uh two things one
stationary markov nash equilibria
are definitely hard right because
uh stochastic games are more general
than single round like normal form games
where there's a single state
uh and over there uh
finding nash equilibrium is pretty hard
from my work and other people's work so
definitely you can't hope to compute
stationary nash equilibria in this case
all right so uh work has studied two
settings instead
one is the
two player zero sum case of markov
of stochastic games where
you know
the problem you know
is tractable
and
at least as far as computing approximate
nash equilibria is concerned or
correlated equilibrium like this course
correlated equilibria i was talking
about before
um
however in contrast to normal from games
so games with a single state where
course correlate equilibria are a very
nice thing they're computable by linear
programs
and they you can arrive at these types
of equilibria by by running no regret
learning so course correlated equilibria
in single state stochastic games are
very very tractable
experience with
stochastic games
shows that they're not
as tractable in this case at least
existing algorithms
there are no known algorithms that are
polytime and you know if you are also
learning polysample
complexity
except algorithms that are output that
violate one of these properties like
either outputting non-markovian or
non-stationary policies
so what i want to ask here is why what
is it that uh
you know single state games are
tractable and the moment
you know you have a
state interaction uh you know the the
problem appears to be uh challenging
so the main
the main contribution of uh this segment
of the talk is that there is a reason
why that happens and it's pretty
surprising
we show that
even
when you have a two players to cast the
game
even when the discount factor is a half
which basically means that
the expected interaction is two steps
okay so the scan factor is huge
uh you expect to interact with the other
agent for two steps okay
uh uh the problem of computing core
score lyric libra becomes really hard
all right so like one state
very tractable
if you expect to interact with the other
agent two states two steps
it becomes intractable
this is very very very surprising
and of course you know if you if you
have longer interactions the problem is
even harder so
uh it's even more intractable
this is quite quite surprising
uh in the interest of time i'm not gonna
give you the sketch of the proof which
was only gonna be this one
uh and uh just conclude with some
thoughts of what might be computable or
actually
let me skip that in the interest of time
so we have some positive results in the
paper where we
show how to learn
non-stationary markov ccs in this case
non-stationary markov ccs are
policies that are markov but they are
time dependent that change with time
so in that case we we provide efficient
uh algorithms for learning uh such
uh policies and that that i think is an
interesting
uh thing to do in this case because
multi-agent reinforcement learning
settings are very important
and the fact that uh stationary markov
ccs are not even tracked up not even
these are tractable
you know uh
would require you to compromise to
something like non-stationary of
policies
that's all i had to say
um
uh
i think that the broader topic discussed
in this talk is very unexplored as i was
saying earlier game theory has broadly
focused on a case in on cases where
utilities are concave
uh in one's own actions and there are
many uh directions to uh be explored
here a very fertile ground and with
important practical implications so i
encourage everybody to
try to think about it and work on it so
thank you very much
thank you costas for the great talk and
uh i'm entering the chat uh if anyone uh
watching online has any questions please
type in the chat otherwise i'll take
questions from the room first
so what about just the last thing you
were telling us about i i
either i misunderstand it or it seems to
me you're overstating the the result
because
um
you're making this distinction between a
game that's unrepeated in a game where
you expect two interactions but it seems
like expect is doing a lot of work there
because
if i know that there are two
interactions it collapses back to to a
normal form game right so
i mean then it would really just be an
extensive form you know an imperfect
information extensive form game with two
interactions and that would have an
induced normal form that was finite and
then you'd be back in the single
interaction correct so so it seems like
really what's going on here is that the
expectation isn't very important and
it's the fact that the game can go on
infinitely
um you know regardless of the discount
factor that must be driving the results
that's not the important distinction uh
if you try to write it as a normal form
game
the equilibrium that we'll get are
non-stationary so there will be like uh
the ones discussed over here so like
that if you try to i mean
it's not the expectation of two
interactions that's really doing the
work the intuition is that the fact that
that you're shooting for this markov
stationary equilibria is the problem uh
the moment you relax your notion to
non-stationary so like if you were to
write a normal form description of this
two-stage or multi-stage game uh the
types of equilibria you would see
you know would not necessarily be markov
stationery
and you know that problem is tractable
and the challenge here is to
you know can you like if the game is
unknown can you learn it and this is the
contribution of this slide i didn't talk
about
but uh you are correct to say like if i
can write the normal form i could solve
that but it's not going to be a
stationary mark of nash a mark of
correlated equilibrium so even if you
knew the game stopped after two
interactions but you wanted to do this
stationary concept
uh i think you would i mean i i haven't
uh i mean you would definitely like by
if you write an lp you'll definitely
get a non-stationary now a
non-stationary cc i i haven't looked
that specifically to rounds okay so
that's interesting but like uh again uh
this normal form description misses the
stationarity here yeah
yeah also related to that but you also
want the reduction maybe i misunderstood
the question but you want the reduction
in the other direction right you want to
take an arbitrary game and reduce it to
this
two-stage game or something
for the hardness result yeah so he's
talking about upper bounds that's why
he's complaining about like
why did this complexity arise
and uh indeed the complexity arises
because of this stationarity of the
policies that we're requesting
uh uh uh yeah uh for for the lord like
if you want to prove a lower bounds you
have to start with an arbitrary uh um
um
ppd complete problem uh and reduce it to
a you know multi-stage interaction uh
like the ones that's what you do in this
that's what we desire yeah
any other questions
[Music]
i had one other curiosity question so in
this game between gan and discriminator
current state of the art with neural
networks who's winning
so there are very good gowns out there
but
maybe motivated by this challenge that
i'm talking about there's a lot of work
in
providing a framework for training deep
generative models that are not based on
a game but purely minimization problems
so there are several recent frameworks
that train degenerative models
writing down a minimization problem like
these are called score based models or
flow
models and
they are competitive uh to the practical
behavior of guns
is that a question yeah
uh yeah i want to continue like a
previous discussion like there's a
non-concave like max organization
problem
so you mentioned like there may not be
equilibrium right
but also like some other international
like
if we just discretize the entire space
then there could be equilibrium
uh so it essentially is it corresponds
to you you use some mixed strategy
correct and uh and again i mean i think
it so far my first question is like
uh if you you build me max organization
yeah sorry in my conversation it sounds
like a constraint set then there should
be a
mix
right so that's a great question so
first of all like this is a bit beside
my specific talk because
i'm not talking about guns specifically
but
indeed like if you discretize the space
to a finite number of possible
parameterizations of the gun and
consider distributions over them
if your set is finite definitely there
exists uh you know distributions over
these finite spaces where
those are equilibria
now another thing you may do which is a
little bit more sophisticated is to not
discretize but still ask questions about
whether uh mixed nash exists
now that goes up against you know the
lower bound of guess the larger number
game that i mentioned earlier
but you know like recent work that i
have with noah uh
uh i think it's so in stock this year uh
uh gives conditions uh under which
equilibria exists uh in this in this
infinite uh uh games mixed nash and or
mixed correlated sorry or correlated
libra in these games and the and you
know the answer relates a little bit to
the online
to uh little sun dimension and you know
sequential or the market complexity of
some function classes that really like
that relate to to the underlying game so
that is you know definitely uh something
to try
my perspective is for guns that wouldn't
make sense but uh you know uh uh
theoretically thinking about this uh
question is very interesting and there
are
many interesting things to consider
there yeah yeah maybe a second just a
second question so
uh so is it possible to like circumvent
this difficulty by by doing something
like improv learning so do you really
maintain some mixed model
uh you you're not talking about games
right
[Music]
uh
there's a lot of things you can do
properly
i mean as i said earlier this relates to
another learnability
ability proper non-profit makes a
difference so there are things you can
do in that space
uh i know that both of the papers have
been published very very recently but in
the case that you have a comment i would
like to learn about it
uh there is a very concurrent work of
art own
video and user speak about
the turn-based
games right and where there is the issue
that actually because the turn-based mvp
in its state you play exactly one uh
one player actually cc's
yeah yeah i would like a comment to
understand what are the differences
what's the difference between two years
yeah
so um
but all right so this is the part that i
didn't get to
uh so there's simultaneous work by jin
kumar and sid ford they show the same
result except uh
these two becomes uh
end so it's uh
and basically okay so like roughly
speaking the difficulties that in the in
the
in the complexity proof
uh one thing you can do is you can start
with like a
uh you know and player game and to
reduce to the stochastic game
and the easiest thing to do is to
replicate every agent in the the game
you start with with a state in your
stochastic game and assign that state to
a single player moving there okay this
is where round based
so um
so if you wanna if you are you know if
you want to prove a hardness it's all
for antler
and player stochastic game so if if
there's a
num a number
there is a single legend playing at
every step stage every every state of
that stochastic game uh uh you can you
can get that uh
you get that more easily and a lot of
the hard work we need to do to prove the
two player games to actually argue that
you don't need to assign a different
player playing never in in every state
but like you can
have players play like
uh
playing in multiple states uh where they
have to take into account like okay like
my actions here in the state
what impact would like how would they
influence the probability of each other
states where i also i'm playing and so
on so forth so
uh but uh yeah so uh the two results are
similar the difference is that uh here
you have two agents so it's an easier
problem
that you show is hard here you have
equal number of agents and states i see
thank you thank you very much
[Music]
thank you for the great talk um so in
the last couple of uh the last decades i
think like deep learning has been pretty
disrupt disrupt disrupt story
district this
this
respectful or disrespectful okay with
like lower bounds
yeah we had you know it was supposed to
be hard to find global minima it's
supposed to be hard to distinguish local
minima with saddle points so uh what
about yours do you think deep learning
is actually hitting your lower bound or
because in practice for instance in the
results you showed
uh we are reaching something bad for the
generation but it's it's sort of a fixed
point you know
okay i guess you you okay so you're
talking about two different things like
are we talking about gans are we talking
about general non-concave games yeah i
would say like anything where there is a
deep learning application yeah i mean
anything against it's again that exists
at deep learning exciting that's
multi-agent where there's no problem
right so there exists right so like
location
guess the point of this talk is
like
in non-convex minimization problems
uh you are guaranteed to convert to
local min in probably one of our
excellent steps
right so you have like whatever model
you write
you are guaranteed like the the the
single method of growing descent will
give you an absolute min
local mean in probably one of our
absolute steps
in the result not this specific result
because this is a pvd hardness results
but my query complexity lower bound i
was talking about earlier
you cannot have such a guarantee like
there's no
and that is problematic from the
perspective of uh having a framework of
for multi-agent learning right so like
in single laser learning you know write
anymore you want put it on tensorflow
gradient descent you will get an epsilon
now an epsilon local minimum
over here you you don't have you lose
this guarantee that's a has nothing to
do with complex it's just a query
complexity lower bound you don't have
such query complex level bands for
minimization problems immunization
problems probably one of our options
suffices over here you need expert
one over epsilon that's a query
complexity lower bounds
uh that's not the hardness result now if
you also believe you know the hardness
of people are in that you know like down
nice are talking about average case and
so on so forth
and then you know
maybe there are some if the analysis but
uh i think this query complexity bond is
very stark very problematic i mean it
just removes the guarantee you have from
gradient descent
in minimization problems
there's a couple of questions in the
chat from the same person so
is there a way to have zero some game in
the learning environment
and what are the causal effects of an
agent's actions in rl environments can
our measurements of an agent's actions
affect its learning environment what was
the question okay
is there a way to have a zero-sum game
in the learning environment the
reinforcement learning
yeah yeah definitely there is i mean
like two players playing a basketball
against each other is a two player zero
sum uh
reinforcement learning problem
uh and what was the song the second
question is what are the causal effects
of an agent's actions in rl environments
and can our measurement of an agent's
actions affect its learning environment
oh yeah so the cause i mean i guess you
know like uh yeah the causal effects is
like what you anticipate that your
actions will incentivize the other agent
to do
and they're thinking about the same
thing
so you have this fixed point uh
interaction
and uh yeah this you know this you know
this uh anticipatory uh planning is what
uh introduced a lot of the complexity of
this problem
one thing i should mention though is
that which also is pretty surprising
if the game is
like in the in the classical setting
started by uh sharply there is a mini
max theorem for uh you know stationary
mark of nash equilibria which is also
another
pretty cool thing that these stochastic
games have like zero sums stochastic
games have
a mini max theorem for stationary markov
nash equilibria right so min and max can
be
swapped which is cool
and for your lower bound is there an
approximate notion of stationarity that
will bypass it uh which lower bound the
affordable care act yeah
the picpad for two players if you only
require some sort of like epsilon
approximate station i think
uh so so
stationery i see uh local i mean so this
is for approximate like we say that even
for constant approximation this is hard
where the epsilon goes to your best
response to the stationary the the value
so like uh you want a value you want you
want that no switching your policy
you have if you allow for
time sensitive but you have like
approximate stationarity you cannot oh
approximately i see uh like oh i see
sorry yeah yeah so this epsilon is not
stationarities on the value so that's a
good question ah so um
approximate stationarity uh
i think there are stuff you can do if
you buy yeah if you violate the session
i mean like
like any i mean there is this result
right that any game
you can truncate the horizon at uh
you can pretend that there's no future
be beyond one over one or gamma steps
and
your stationarity can be at most needs
to only be at most this much like if you
only need to remember this many things
in the past
uh now you're asking about like what
like memory two or three or something
small
maybe the distribution of actions could
change at most
by at most something in between or like
some measure of stability
my guess is that
my guess is that this wouldn't cut it
because
i'm pretty sure the proof can be
robustified to
not care so much about the most recent
history but i have to think about that
that's a great question but a general
commando is this that you only need to
remember this many steps because
of the of the like if you were to allow
more memory yeah and also if you have
some form of like fast mixing-ness for
any
action then would that
be enough
uh fast mixing this meaning
like no matter what actually there's
like you know from every state i go to
every other state with some probability
i don't think that would cut it probably
because i'm pretty sure we can hook up
everything and
uh you know still have the hard distance
hidden there with a lot of hooking up
and
i don't think that would fix it either
but okay great questions yeah these are
our speculative answers
yeah thanks everyone for the great
questions and discussions maybe we'll if
there are further questions probably
take it offline and uh thanks again to
courses for the great talk discussion